AI is rapidly taking over the world
dissolving jobs across sectors evolving
at an exponential rate and quickly
becoming smarter than most adults what
goes through most of our heads are shows
and movies like iRobot Matrix her and
Westworld it's obviously exciting but
it's also scary as is this the beginning
of the end for all non-tech jobs are we
years months or days out from
obsolescence I want to find out how
close we really are so I paid for an AI
program to find out if it could replace
a dietitian and I asked it to make me a
diet plan let me show you what it did
hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen
[Music]
in today's video I'm going to be eating
a diet plan recommended by AI now a
quick trigger warning as we will be
mentioning calories so please feel free
to skip this video if it's not
supportive to you I want to quickly pop
in here to type up my sponsor cerebral
so I've been very open about my
struggles with anxiety insomnia and
mental health and considering that at
least 50 of the general population has a
mental health condition I know that I'm
not alone I acknowledge that I've been
super privileged to be able to access
therapists and doctors and other
supporters when I need them but I know
how many of you message me to tell me
that there are so many Financial time
and stigma related barriers to getting
the help that you need so I was really
excited when I heard about cerebral
cerebral is a 100 online mental health
service that provides access to therapy
and medication management or anxiety
depression insomnia and ADHD in some
states all for a flat monthly rate it's
super convenient because they they
operate on your schedule where you can
work calls or video visits in when it
works for you in a place that is most
private and discreet for you so you no
longer have to worry about how much
travel time it'll take to get to and
from your therapist's office they have
three convenient plans for care that
their simple questionnaire process will
help you navigate to find the best
option for your needs so their
medication management plan their
medication plus therapy and their
therapy plan and your care team will
work together to help develop the best
treatment plan for you and they have
Specialists who work in areas like grief
stress family trauma and much more and
if you've struggled to afford mental
health care in the past cerebral Works
differently so you can start cerebral
with or without insurance and without
coverage you're looking at costs that
can be up to three times less than
traditional therapy it's just one flat
monthly rate and a more affordable price
cerebral also has a mobile app available
on Google and the App Store so you can
easily message your team from your phone
and get access to extra Care Resources
so this sounds like it may be helpful
for you or others check out the link in
my description to take the questionnaire
and get 50 off of your first month of
cerebral all right Abby let's do it the
world of AI really fascinates me and I
think a lot of people have looked at
what AI is being able to accomplish in
like just the last five years and they
think like that's pretty amazing but I
don't think a lot of people recognize
that AI is exponential technology so
what we've seen it accomplish in the
last five years is nothing compared to
what we're gonna see in the next five
years I'm not even sure like our minds
are able to compute or imagine what
that's going to look like I'm excited
albeit kind of scared so let's take a
look at what my AI dietitian told me to
eat write me a one day healthy meal plan
with detailed recipes for a 35 year old
female 5'7 looking to maintain her
weight okay
we can do this you know it's not
actually that far off from kind of some
of the things that I normally eat maybe
a little boring but we can work with
this okay so let's start with breakfast
we have blueberry banana overnight oats
very 2015. though I do feel like this is
understandable considering that
overnight oats is still like at the very
top of all the like healthy breakfast
listicles not to mention I think that I
have pretty much all of these
ingredients right now uh oats Chia low
calorie unsweetened almond milk of
course so you know fits the healthy bill
as most people online May imagine it
also it's vegan which AI probably can
see is still a very popular search term
right now so that makes sense so yeah
let's start making some oats okay I feel
like I'm reading this over and over and
over again looking for the caffeine
um apparently you need to specify that
you are are a mom and you desperately
need your coffee in the morning in this
healthy meal plan so I just took the
liberty of making myself one anyways
because we all know I can't go on
without it
okay first things first
oats gonna follow their measurements
they specified in exact recipes pretty
standard ratios here half a cup
couple tablespoons of chia
they say plain almond milk I say that's
boring I got some chocolate almond milk
because I mean why not add some extra
flavor
all right I am not measuring even though
they say I should be half a banana okay
that's a good hack it adds natural
sweetness so we don't have to add a ton
of added sugar
you kind of like mash that in
this is not how you properly mash and
some cinnamon
and maple syrup
how much a teaspoon
stingy
that looks about right though I am kind
of curious what AI would say about maple
syrup being healthier than like any
other sugar no maple syrup is not
healthier than white sugar although
maple syrup does contain some
antioxidants it is still a type of sugar
and is not considered a healthier choice
than white sugar I mean that's pretty
close to what I would probably say in
this situation as well yes some extra
antioxidants and nutrients But
ultimately the same effect on the body
as white sugar and we really shouldn't
be aiming to get our antioxidants from
sugar anyway so enjoy whichever
sweetener you like in moderation and
move on I do like maple syrup though I
love the flavor it is Canadian so great
choice I do think we need a little more
liquid here
now full disclosure I know they're
calling for overnight oats but your girl
don't have time for that and also it's
like -10 outside and I just prefer my
oats warm so I'm going to pop these in
the microwave and we're gonna do it our
way so this is basically what we got I
already made one adjustment which was to
use the chocolate almond milk because I
needed a little something extra I feel
like this is just not going to be enough
for me on its own for breakfast I know
for my body I need a little more protein
in the morning so I'm gonna add a scoop
of chocolate protein powder all right
make a mess as always probably use a
little more milk just to loosen her up
are you guys team thick oats or do you
like them soupy because I kind of like
them a little more on the soupy side
come at me I don't care so that's going
down
then it also calls for a quarter cup of
blueberries I mean this feels like
very limited okay that's a quarter cup
and sorry AI that is just looking a
little sad for me so we're gonna Gussy
this up a little more make it a bit more
Abby style some banana on top there you
go uh let's add some peanut butter I
feel like she could use some healthy
fats and dollop and since we're going
with this like chocolate peanut butter
deliciousness
theme I need crunch I can't have just
like a bowl of soupy oats
just one texture one note little nuts
sweet and salty
and
a little Oreo
some Oreo on top AI take note
okay so I feel like this is a major
upgrade from your basic boring overnight
oats recipe it's like they gave me the
base recipe the kind of recipe that
you'd see on a blog post that's trying
to rank for like number one spot on
Google where they just want to give you
the absolute Basics but this is way more
fun and we got protein in the protein
powder we got lots of healthy fats
between the Chia nut butter and nuts on
top lots of healthy fiber rich carbs in
our fruit and our Oats not to mention we
got a little chocolate and Oreo in there
let's go in for a taste test
um
all right I'm ready for a little midday
snack let's see what AI has planned
chocolate almond energy bites sounds
about right I feel like energy bites or
energy balls or powerballs whatever you
want to call them had quite a moment
like five years ago basically my
Pinterest feed was just balls what
so yeah I'm really not surprised that
this made the snack list and I'm pretty
sure I have all of these ingredients so
let's do it all right first things first
some relish again oats sticking to the
heart healthy theme here okay I think AI
has subscribed to the notion that almond
butter is inherently healthier than
peanut butter I think they're both great
they've got different health benefits
but peanut butter is actually high in
protein just an FYI uh this looks about
right about a quarter cup
again
not measuring
um flax excellent source of heart
healthy omega-3s
what
right
all right all right
honey
vanilla
and these are going to be chocolate
flavors we've got some cocoa powder
and I don't need a health reason to eat
chocolate but I'm curious but it's
rationale here for the cocoa AI what are
the health benefits of cocoa powder
she's right
rich in antioxidants May improve blood
flow and lower blood pressure May
improve brain function may help regulate
blood sugar levels and may help reduce
inflammation this is all evidence-based
and true so I say all the more reason to
add more
recipe didn't call for chocolate chips
but I cannot imagine an energy ball
without them
okay so they're more like energy clumps
than energy balls but I assume they'll
still taste okay they're cute
I'm pretty good yes they look a bit like
turds but they are nutrient packed I
mean we got lots of fiber protein and
healthy fats from the flax and the
almond butter and a lot of fiber in the
oats and as we established some very
very nutritious chocolate
yum
okay got some work done it's time for
lunch let's see what's on the menu
avocado and chickpea wrap how dietitian
of it this recipe is just a whole wheat
wrap avocado chickpeas Tomatoes diced
onions olive oil and lemon juice this is
given mad Weight Watchers magazine meal
plan Vibes and I guess this is kind of
one area where AI lacks it doesn't have
taste buds not yet at least so I feel
like it doesn't know that a lot of these
recipes will probably lack flavor it is
plant-based though and I'm pretty sure
everything in this day is plant-based
which I didn't ask for so I'm assuming
that AI has a sense that this is kind of
what is considered healthy right now
maybe based on food guys maybe based on
kind of new articles and research coming
out and speaking of that I am curious to
see what it says about a vegan diet is a
vegan diet healthy yes a vegan diet can
be healthy it's important to make sure
that a vegan diet includes all essential
vitamins and minerals and plenty of
fruits vegetables legumes nuts and whole
grains eating a variety of these foods
can help ensure that a vegan diet is
balanced and nutritious this is
definitely true though not necessarily
very helpful just to say include all
your vitamins without specifying which
vitamins where you get them how much you
need of them Etc but I am just glad the
AI didn't compute me like a carnivore
diet based on some of the recent Tick
Tock Trends so let's make this lunch
always feels good I am taking some
serious liberties with this lackluster
recipe because the idea of just eating
like some smash chickpeas on a tortilla
with a few pieces of onion and tomato
just makes me sad so okay we are going
to start with the avocado though all
right throw you guys down just like that
chickpeas drained and rinsed a couple
tomatoes
and that's basically what they
recommended I eat for lunch so I'm gonna
add cheese because that automatically
makes my life better and some salsa
foreign
I feel like barbecue sauce is that weird
hot sauce it needs some hot sauce
and I got some iceberg lettuce the OG
the classic how am I going to wrap this
up stretch baby stretch and don't rip
I'm not gonna be able to tuck no
now what my plans are foiled this is why
they kept it really simple guys but I
will not be defeated stay stay
we got a random Starbucks stopper in
with my kids toothpicks you know what
it'll do and because that might be a
complete disaster let's serve her up
with some veggies and hummus on the side
I feel like there's a little boat going
into my mouth
[Music]
that's a lot better than just some
onions olive oil and lemon juice on some
chickpeas just saying
it's snack o'clock let's see what we
have apple with almond butter snore
right like could this be any more
conventionally boring alas
let's do it so I never really got the
whole like just an apple with almond
butter on the side just doesn't Light My
Fire so I'm gonna make these like little
apple donut Rings we'll call them not to
be confused with actual Donuts which are
like obviously way better
go nuts but understandably
not on today's menu I'm gonna cut out
the middle
with a fun
little cookie cutter which I just broke
naturally
way more complicated than just dipping
an apple and almond butter but that's
how we roll
oh that's the technique
okay now
on our plate butter
see almond butter just doesn't spread
like peanut butter
it's too thick
damn you AI damn you I'm just gonna
change the whole thing because
it's my life you get that AI my life
you're not gonna replace me you're not
gonna replace my autonomy
we're doing peanut butter instead
because as you can see she spreads
better all right I got some freeze-dried
strawberries because I just I love the
flavor I love the crunch I'm all about
texture I'm all about different flavors
and this just makes it so much more fun
it's like kind of like a peanut butter
jelly situation here
a little hemp hearts if you know you
know I guess AI doesn't know about the
glory of hemp hearts
and because like everything's more fun
with sprinkles
birthday cake apple and almond butter AI
take that
um
all right we are on the home stretch for
dinner we are having
roasted veg and quinoa Bowl again seems
pretty predictable and this also just
confirmed that the entire day is vegan
though looking at dinner I'm gonna say
this is a lot more fodmaps than my body
is used to processing maybe I should
have given it more Direction on some of
my preferences or the fact that I have
IBS and I need to kind of cut back or
limit certain foods and eat them in
moderation there's also only 12 grams of
protein in this Meal which again
probably not enough to keep me satisfied
personally especially like just before
bed also I don't like quinoa I really
don't like quinoa I know what a terrible
dietitian thing to say because quinoa is
like the quintessential healthy grain so
I'm gonna cut the quinoa thingy out and
I'm gonna have to get my protein
elsewhere and speaking of protein I am
definitely curious what it has to say
about my unique protein needs let's take
a look a moderately active female of 35
years old would need approximately
0.45 to 0.68 grams of protein per pound
of body weight to build muscle this
would mean she would need to consume 56
to 78 grams of protein each day aha
something I actually disagree with this
isn't the very low side in my opinion I
mean there's definitely a lot of
conflicting expert opinions and research
on this topic but most agree that the
sweet spot for muscle growth is between
0.7 and 1 gram of protein per pound of
body weight so that would mean for me at
least 88 grams of protein per day so
let's bump that up a bit okay so if we
do this the AI way we literally just put
some quinoa down and top it with some
roasted veg that's not gonna fly for me
first off I skipped the quinoa because
as we established I don't love it and I
did some Israeli couscous instead which
I'm obsessed with so that step one
uh we've got our roasted veg let's throw
that down and because we are skipping
the quinoa which is basically the only
source of protein in this meal and
albeit not that much I'm gonna add some
leftover rotisserie chicken here for
some extra protein I feel like this
needs more flavor there's no sauce on
this there's just like nothing going on
I don't even know if it calls for salt
does yes thank God okay I'm gonna do a
little bit of tahini
[Applause]
a little bit of maple
Touch of apple cider vinegar Boop
and a little olive oil
and of course some salt and pepper
add a stir a little more a little boil
just to thinner out
excellent
okay A little drizzle on top
I'm going to finish with a little zatar
some feta cheese
a little salty bite
some pistachios I don't know about you
guys but I feel like this is a major
upgrade from some plain steamed quinoa
with some roasted veg
so what
well it seems
it is certainly capable of creating a
meal plan that is roughly within
nutrition guidelines at least
calorically speaking this plan was
roughly 2 000 calories almost on the dot
which is generally what's recommended
for most adult women so I assume that's
what AI was kind of focusing its efforts
on when I calculated the macros though
it only provided 53 grams of protein and
instead focused on the 57 grams of fiber
246 grams of carbs and 98 grams of fat
which is kind of one area where I feel
like it trips up that breaks down to 10
of the calories from protein 50 from
carbs and 40 percent from fats and I
know just personally that's way more
fats and definitely not enough protein
for my body to thrive ditto for the
fiber I think this is probably way more
fiber and more fodmaps than what most
people are able to comfortably stomach
considering that most people don't even
meet the bare minimum recommendation
never mind like doubling it it's also
pretty clear that AI was just kind of
pulling from the top rated healthy
generic recipes on Google which is fine
I mean everyone's got to start somewhere
even AI but alas this definitely leaves
a lot to be desired in the flavor and
culinary creativity Department it's also
worth mentioning that I am a white woman
and I am already accustomed to a lot of
these white washed health foods like
Chia flax oats and quinoa but a dialect
this would just not be culturally
appropriate for folks who are accustomed
to consuming things like rice or noodles
or fish or tortillas Etc this has
traditionally being an issue in the
world of nutrition and dietetics which I
do think we are trying to address by
diversifying the profession but it does
kind of seem like this AI is stuck in
nutrition 101 Circa 2010. that said
thank God I have taste buds and some
culinary skills so that I can kind of
like MacGyver these recipes fees to make
them more suitable to my tastes and
desires so I definitely do think that
tools like this could be a great start
for a lot of folks though not a complete
replacement for individualized Care at
least not yet let's Circle back in a few
months and see where it's at and on that
note folks that is all that I have for
you guys today if you like this video be
sure to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below with your thoughts on this
world of AI subscribe to the channel and
I'll see you next time on Abby's kitchen
bye
thank you